on the way to hospital struggling to
breathe Dave hunt didn't know it at the
time but he was minutes from being put
on a ventilator for me that was it I was
like really thought so called my brother
he gave my password sort of moment well
was he woke up two days later in the
same intensive care unit where the prime
minister is now alive and my dad you
know I was clearly alive but I had a
fifteen-inch you know hose pipe in my
mouth I couldn't you talk he describes
it as organized chaos with few staff for
many patients intensive care is not a
fun place to be
you see people die it's absolutely
horrible I sell software for a living
right I'm not a nurse or a doctor can
you see people just getting wheeled it
out wielded in I just wanted to get out
of that place at 38 years old he was one
of the youngest in ICU was kovat 19 and
moved to the high dependency unit after
four days they removed the tube which
was a horrendous experience I still
couldn't talk my throat was swollen I
still had a feeding tube in my nose ten
tubes coming out of my neck through luck
with the main the main injection there
even when about to be discharged the
pain went on I've seen things even in my
last war there was a guy diagonally
opposite me I saw him take his last
breaths you know so he kind of it has
affected me mentally and that's what
really annoys me when I see people out
and about just just not taking it
seriously enough you know until you see
somebody physically take their last
breath without a friend or family there
it's horrendous
it really is but without the dedicated
medical team he says he wouldn't have
survived Boris Johnson will be in good
care you know I take my hat off to all
of them
because without them I'm pretty sure I
wouldn't be here almost certainly he's
been home for a week and told he's not
contagious and he's now involved in
trials to try to learn more about the
disease
Alex Crawford Sky News London